so
so
so
[Applause]
[Music]
happy week 11 everybody you just tapped
into the vr betting squad ride presented
by draftkings live in the bleacher
report app i'm connor rogers the man
alongside me is sizzling hot right now
because he won his boldest bet last week
so you're going to want to stick around
and hear what he has to say this week
craig we're getting close to
thanksgiving how we feeling man
getting close to thanksgiving feeling
good connor feeling good actually
feeling so good i'm giving away a hoodie
right now i got jj snell in the comments
he's giving us a kurt cousins gift uh
he's dancing so he's feeling good so
shout out to you jj snell i'm feeling
good connor i hope you are feeling good
uh we're all feeling good man uh let's
let's get this thing on the road connor
i'm feeling great and let's find these
touchdown scorers you know the drill by
now every single week that's what we're
looking for we asked you on social we
ask you in the app who are locks to find
the end zone and as you see at the top
of the board nick chubb back and ready
to rumble against a sorry lions defense
that's one that i'll have my eyes on aj
dillon getting some workhorse
opportunity with aaron jones banged up
and out this week jonathan taylor he's
saved us many many times this year dk
metcalf and now cd lamb noah mari cooper
this week so more touches for cd lamb
and michael gallup as well you see
justin jefferson on the board cam newton
making his return in carolina
everybody's jacked up for that and derek
carr what the heck is he doing on that
board plus 550. he get on the list yeah
that feels like the uh i got to make
some money to buy christmas gifts for my
relatives real quick let's see if derek
carr can get his butt in the end zone
this week all right to get things going
here let's take a look at some of our
favorite videos from last week that
weren't featured on the show
this week we got
jonathan taylor
najee harris
alvin kamara
man has nine touchdowns in the last six
games against the jegs at home first to
the ground wins
[Music]
this man's about to go beast mode on
them jags here we go
first to the ground
we have the winner
gary judy anytime sounds good any time
touchdown jonathan taylor it's a lock
jonathan taylor guaranteed touchdown
this sunday let's go
the lock legend's coming in hot greg
what are we giving away today
connor i'm not only giving away hoodies
i'm also giving away one
psych not only not one but two nfl
jerseys today uh one goes to the winning
lock legend and one goes to a lucky
commenter like you so stay tapped in
stay tuned don't go anywhere
if you want hoodies you want uh jerseys
i just need gifts i need emojis but most
importantly i need winners
only please actually type that right now
winners only please in the comments i'm
giving out a hoodie let's get it done
all right we have four legendary picks
to show you you know the drill the last
one standing is the squad ride leader
they get the title they also get to
bring home that nfl jersey we're going
to trail them if we like that pick you
know the deal by now our first pitch
comes from jack and kilos tell us who's
scoring a touchdown today
what's up guys my name is jackson and
i'm here to tell you it's guaranteed
money that cam newton scores a touchdown
tomorrow let's keep pounding
jackson exploding out of that shmedium
cam newton jersey respect my guy with
some muscle ups there all right first
decision of the day we got our second
pitch from master sneaky
when in doubt go to snapchat and ask
your friends
or
maybe
fade your friends
let's see what they got here
yeah greg do you think this i haven't
used
snapchat in a long time
i was literally about to say i'm i don't
think i'm a snapchat guy anymore you
know your boy gallop is going to score
hey gallop is on my fantasy team so i
actually like
uh
gallop scoring but it looks like my guy
he faded did he fade his guy and went cd
any time
he did yeah yeah he gave him the old
rope-a-dope there he said what do you
got okay cool i'll go with the other
thing all right cam newton plus money cd
lam plus money greg and i we like plus
money how are we feeling about these
right now
i'm feeling good connor feeling really
good but what i need the people to do is
get in the comments and tell me if we
should ride with
the muscle up legend or the snapchat
legend cam newton cd lamb let's talk
about it connor we got cam newton facing
his former coach riverboat ron uh and
the washington football team
we know what the carolina panthers like
to do when they get in the red zone
especially with cam newton i mean we saw
it last week
power right power left with my boy
superman cam uh so
i i actually like this plus 120 i i like
this a lot cd lamb no amari cooper no
amari cooper we know about that dallas
offense and how powerful they are connor
which way are you leading yeah these are
great picks i just think by now and
we've said this for years if you don't
know what's coming against cam newton
inside the five-yard line by now god i
mean you gotta stop it at some point you
would think ron rivera knows that as
well but at the end of the day the man
is hard to tackle he's six foot six like
240 pounds i'm gonna roll with cd lamb
here greg i just think there's at least
10 maybe 12 targets on the table from
him with no amari cooper out the chief
secondary scares absolutely no one so i
really like cd here but these are both
really fun picks let's get our first
decision of the day from that comment
section i am in the comments right now
connor i'm in the comments right now and
uh
i got aaron sham says aaron sham 45 says
lamb is the man
today shout out to you aaron sham45 you
can uh you are walking away with the
hoodie i got uh
sas squelch sasquatch says cam cam the
man going to win my league for me so
he's rocking with cam and this uh santa
cam is going to help him win his fantasy
team hey connor next one i choose we're
just going to rock with it okay i have
uh
i got isaac boatman isaac boatman says
lamb he's he's he's just commenting lamb
so many times shout out to you isaac
boatman you are walking away with a
hoodie uh it appears we're moving on
with cd lamb in the snap chat legend
they're moving on to the next round
connor yeah master sneaky snapchat
legend with cd lamb moving on to round
number two but they got a ways to go all
right next pitch comes from benavidez
who is scoring a touchdown today
what's up vr betting i got to make this
quick anytime touchdown score prop bet
for you lock of the week
some people they go to a fortune teller
some people use a magic 8 ball i use the
magic bullet never wrong
let's see what it gives us
anytime for the week
aj dylan lock it in let's win together
the magic bullet legend going with the
new workhorse and aj
dillon that man
uh is ready to rumble every single week
and he's gonna have a lot of touches so
this is minus here we're going minus
125. we still got cd lamb at the plus
money this is going to be interesting
everybody loves those running backs to
get in the end zone you know the guy
next to me and greg likes to get these
boosted up into plus money just change
your mind at all here greg
ah connor this one is
tough this one's tough but let me talk
to the people i need you guys to get in
the comments and tell me are we rocking
with aj dylan and the magic bullet
legend or are we going with the snapchat
legend and c d
lamb let's talk about aj dylan we know
the green bay packers like to run the
ball to get aaron rodgers going
uh but
i just don't know if i want to rock with
aj dylan over cd lamp see lambs plus
money connor he's plus money so you know
what we can do here we can just boost
that right on up uh but it's not up to
me it's up to the people connor which
way are you leading do you like aj dylan
or you like cd land i like both of them
but i'm going to roll with cd lamb just
because i like the odds better and once
again i think the cowboys are going to
put up a lot of points like minnesota
they get hot and cold that defense and
you know aj dillon is a good bet because
he's got no other backs around him to
take away carries but for me i'm going
to stick with what works right now and
cd lamb is going to be that dude this
week but
the comments get the ultimate say in
this i want to know what direction
they're going here greg
commons definitely gets the ultimate say
i'm in the handy dandy i don't think i
introduced the handy dandy but this is
right here guys is the handy dandy ipad
this is how you get your hoodies and
jerseys i'm in the comments connor i am
in the comments uh
i i see dylan i see i want to win says
dylan to carry that rock shout out to
you i want to win you are walking away
with the hoodie i also see jay vargas
says aj dillon is a lock
connor i'm just gonna call it right
there i'm gonna call it right there keep
it short sweet and concise and uh aj
dylan the magic bullet
legend the magic bullet legend you are
moving on to the next round the magic
bullet legend moving on so aj dillon
getting lots of love here we got one
more round this is for the title squad
ride leader who we're trailing it's also
for that nfl jersey and stick around
after that because greg's got a little
bit more he's got another nfl jersey
plenty hoodies to give away
final round we brought in a familiar
face a familiar contender in w trammell
making his return let's see what you got
what's up vr nation we're back with
anytime touchdown playing billboard
let's see who we get
the flinco legend going with nick chubb
minus 165 i'll say it right off the bat
greg my favorite pick of the day
especially if you can get that to even
money nick chubb is going to have a
field day against that sorry lines team
the only thing you got to worry about is
them watching his load management at
that point not giving him enough carries
where they rest him if they get up early
but they've been competitive enough
detroit that should be a close game
we got two running backs two monster
running backs that get it done in the
red zone time and time again
this is one of those ones where you
could flip a coin and pick either way is
that what you're doing here gregor do
you feel strongly about a certain guy
connor
let me talk to the people in the
comments first what i need you guys to
do most importantly
is comment let us know are we rocking
with aj dylan
in the magic bullet legend or are we
rocking with the plinko legend and nick
chuck
now connor
i like nick chubb here simply because
he's facing that detroit lions defense
they don't scare anybody we know what
the browns like to do baker mayf
is he we don't even know if he's playing
he's hurt
with that being said we know that
they're gonna pound the rock so
i like this pick you say it's your
favorite pick
it's my favorite pick you know what we
can do i see it's -165 but you know
we're just gonna boost that up uh
connor
you like it right you're in on the nick
chub train right i don't like it i love
it i need the comments to get behind
this pick i need them to push this
across the finish line greg and i only
have so much say in who wins
let's get nick chubb to plus money you
know what to do greg is that enough to
get this one as the squad ride leader
it might be enough it might be enough we
got goldie locks in the comments says
nick chubb will vulture touch his first
game back
meaning he's going to score a touchdown
shout out to you goldilocks you were
walking away with a hoodie uh
i got
one i got another one here i got px1
says chubb and he has a gift
of somebody dancing a little kid dancing
that's so funny shout out to you px1 you
were walking away with it connor i i do
i give away a a a a a a jersey here am i
giving away a jersey here
no jersey for the squad ride leader you
can give away the jersey
for the squad okay okay
okay yeah no no
no jersey here okay i'll i'll give it
away i'll give it away later keep him
waiting but uh
yeah i'll keep i'll keep it waiting but
connor
i think it's apparent if you guys if you
look in the comments that nick chubb is
just running away so we're gonna call
him we're gonna call it here uh nick
chubb is the squad ride leader this week
let's pull up the graphics so i can show
you guys what we can do here on the
squad ride uh you see it's -165
poof
there it is
that's the magic that we can do we just
boosted up we took it from 165
to
uh plus 100 shout out to our friends at
draftkings who boosted the odds for us
check br betting socials for a link to
the odds will send us your screenshots
of your bets let's get rich this sunday
everybody send us your videos and your
celebrations but most importantly we
want winners and winners only to please
that is well done my friend those are
great odds for nick chubb to get in the
end zone i know that's what we'll be
trailing this weekend all right
community comment contest time this week
we basically asked you a simple one
would you bet a hundred dollars on the
panthers those reinvigorated those
rejuvenated panthers with cam back in
the building would you bet a hundred
dollars on them to make playoffs of
course we ask you everywhere for your
best comments we found two of them and
now it's a contest we want to see the
winner the winner takes home the hoodie
greg what do we got from these comments
this week
i need you guys to get in the comments
and tell me which of these is the better
take i'm giving a hoodie to whoever you
guys choose so let's take a look at the
first comment from king psychotic 24
says can't wait for this heartfelt
reunion to crash back to earth
there's a reason they let him go in the
first place he's watched plain and
simple wow this one is a burn
i don't know if he's washed i don't
think cam newswatch but connor
what's your take do you think cam newton
is watched it feels like there's a
little haterade sipping going on here i
think cam can still play i think people
just associate it with if he's not 2015
cam if he's not mvp cam then we don't
want him and i don't think that's fair
at all listen sam darnold was horrific
for the panthers after a couple of good
games
this is an upgrade i don't think it's a
big enough upgrade that i'm carrying all
my cash to the book and betting on the
panthers to make the playoffs so with
that being said i think it's a little
harsh but at the same time
i feel it what else we got in store here
i know we got one more in our pockets
let's see the next comment from
inglewood
mb
says it's only right they make it to the
super bowl versus the patriots whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa slow down we are talking
about the carolina panthers here connor
are you on the train with the panthers
making the super bowl to play the
patriot no it'd be a nice storyline i
think everybody would love to see you
know the team that cut cam newton right
before the season
revenge game everyone loves a redemption
tour everybody loves that
i mean let's be real i don't think
anybody ex
is expecting this matchup to necessarily
happen but i like the vibes i like the
wishful thinking we had the haterade
comment in the first one and now we have
the uh the wishful thinking comment on
the second one i love the comment
contest here do the people have a
favorable side though for either of
these
let me let me let me hop in here
let me hop in here uh
i see uh la troy james is calling
calling him a hater
yeah but
we appreciate the comment we appreciate
the comments uh cam newton cam newton's
about to go off today just watch all the
haters will remember my word shout out
to you 22 goatee you're walking away
with a hoodie uh latrobe james latroll
james said agree gonna be 2015 cam again
shout out to you latroll you are also
walking away with a hoodie um i'm gonna
make a i'm gonna make the decision here
connor i'm just gonna make a decision i
like inglewood and b i just for the
vibes just for the good vibes i like
eagle wood mb sam my boy cam's going to
the super bowl taking on mac jones and
the patriots
what a time i mean what a time if that
actually happens what a time uh so angle
wouldn't be you are walking away with a
hoodie yeah this is a feel-good show so
we had to go with the feel good comment
all right before we get out of here it's
time for our boldest bets and you got
the hot hand right now greg zeke elliott
getting in the end zone not once but
twice last week i hope people trailed
you on that one and made a lot of money
i'm excited to hear what you got this
week what do we need right now
what i need the people to do is get in
the comments and tell me if you guys are
gonna ride with me are you guys gonna
ride with my boy connor
uh connor let's get right to it man
let's get right to it keep it short
sweet and concise what are you taking
brother looking for touchdown scores
again and going back taking a page out
of your playbook and looking at that
dallas offense we had him earlier in the
show i think cd lamb finds his way there
but guess what no amari cooper michael
gallup is healthy i think michael gallup
finds his way there dak is a guy that
can go out and throw three to four
touchdowns every single week with
practically with his eyes closed cd wide
receiver one for them gallop will be
wide receiver two for them the man can
play plus 700 on this greg those are
juicy odds i'll be watching dallas
closely like i said though you got the
hot hand coming into this what are you
bringing this week
connor i did see one go through the hoop
last week uh love your play by the way
brother i got michael gallup on my
fantasy team do ccd also
scoring today uh
but let's talk let's take it let's take
it over to the new york giants tampa bay
game
the total interceptions is sitting at
two and a half and this is a combined
uh interception so tom brady and danny
dimes we know who's playing quarterback
for the giants i just said his name
danny dimes we know what he does
he's facing that tampa bay buccaneers
defense so uh
i can see danny dimes flipping some
coins flipping some flipping some
interceptions and tom brady he's been
struggling lately he's been struggling
lately
tom maybe can flip one maybe two who
knows but uh i think the total will go
over two and a half interceptions in
that ball game today it's in that plus
300 i like it i love that play we'll get
two interceptions out of daniel jones we
get one out of the goat and tom brady
and then you cash your ticket that's a
great play this week all right greg we
need two things before we get out of
here we need one who are the people
riding with hopefully both of us as we
always say two you still have an nfl
jersey gift card to give away
so now so you're telling me now yeah
yeah
it's time to get rid of it yeah
okay uh i'm in the jersey i'm in the
jersey i got a
i got chris paul goat chris paul goat he
says
connor is a lock and just for that chris
paul goat you are walking away with the
nfl jersey environment first choice
because you shout it out my my co-host
man you shout it out my boy connor
he is a legend and he's a lock uh he's a
walking lock actually uh
i am in the comments now connor giving
away hoodies i'm giving away hoodies uh
they i'm seeing love greg all the way
shout out to you jersey your bus
appreciate you uh connor doesn't miss go
white sox let it ride hey
they know what to do they're just
buttering us up yeah let's get seven one
no that was on the ball
the the squad
my bankroll up that's the only thing
keeping it up
hey that's a fact we've been hitting but
we've been hitting uh i just want to
give away one more hoodie let me try to
find somebody i got
jay vark
jose brito jose brito says detroit will
win today no baker mayfield dallas will
blow kansas out and the panthers will
beat washington i love the take i love
the take i love the take so uh
jose you're walking away with a hoodie
all right bowl take uh baker mayfield uh
i don't know if he was ruled out while
we were doing this show or what i think
he's gonna play through some pain but
love them picking some underdogs all
right everyone
good luck with your wagers congrats all
our hoodie and jersey winners you know
the deal by now if you won br betting is
going to reach out to you over the next
24 hours have no fear you'll get your
gear thank you to everyone who commented
thank you the legends jack and kilos
rocking that shmedium cam newton with
the muscle ups master sneaky benavidez w
trammell swooping in at the end and
taking home the title with nick chubb as
our squad ride leader enjoy your
football sunday drop your real time
takes in the sports betting community
streaming the vr app and follow us
follow greg on those ig stories all day
he's always bringing those good vibes
that good energy
alongside the hot hand right now greg
ivory i'm connor rogers greg i was
waiting for you to cut me off right
there and give away one more hoodie i
mean all right here we go here we go
here we go
22 goldie connor picks are great for a
dallas cowboy fan like me and
the uh for dallas cowboy fan like me
let's go
cowboy shout out to you 22 goldie
littler time 100 says
let me get a hoodie i'm a real one for
staying shut up you are a real one for
this thing and you get a hoodie
little time 100 you was walking away
with a hoodie
see you
see you next week same time same place
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you